now this is gonna be one of the big
talking points and today it is the
country's first motorway pub it is on
the m4 tits at the beckons field
services would it encourage you would it
tempt you to have a drink and then maybe
drive a droid Gershon is from the owners
of this pub JD Wetherspoons and he's
there in the pub on the m-40 this
morning and mr. Gershwin I suppose when
it comes to getting planning permission
you mustn't be able to believe your luck
with this one who would have thought I
think quite here that I'm again sorry
you can't believe your luck I'm sure
getting you're getting planning
permission for this one who would have
thought that we'd have pubs on motorways
well you're absolutely right it did
Gaede planning permission it was passed
by the police of a license and
authorities it is a first Poulter
motorway network absolutely right and
we're very pleased that it's a
weatherspoon we believe that people will
actually welcome it they can come off
the motorway coming here have a drink if
they want we are licensed but we believe
majority of people will be drinking hot
drinks coffee a wide range of food and
that they're welcome the fact they can
go somewhere they know they know I'll
pass them around the country instead of
going to sometimes a usual offering in
motorway service stations which can be
less than greater also very expensive
coffee and food and things I mean
there's already lots of outlets where
they can do that you're offering them a
drink and the problem is the first time
there is a fatality on the m-40 and the
driver is linked to your pub you're in
big trouble are you prepared for that
well I don't think you'd be prepared for
what might happen what we would say is
that we act responsibly when we serve
alcohol we believe that customers have
to act responsibly too and if someone
wanted to go less than 50 metres where
I'm standing in - Marcin Spencer's here
at the motor service station they could
get alcohol if they wanted to go less
than a mile off the motorway into a pub
they could do so so we we're happier
they can come in here in a responsible
environment and if they want an
alcoholic drink we will serve them but
we would also serve the responsibly we
will not serve them more than they
should have but I also have to have that
responsibility and we're not hiding from
the fact
that we are serving alcohol what issued
many authorities the shouldn't have any
and your your offering temptation where
it shouldn't be you know as well as I
know yes the possibility exists someone
may pop into Marks and Spencers and sit
there with a bottle of wine in their car
whatever it is but it's highly unlikely
you're actually encouraging people to
drink and you can't say that this is
something that is not going to have a
consequence this seems very strange to
people and as regards who wants this and
you said this seems to be very popular
and the RAC have surveyed this they
should support of only 12% from people
who are looking as people don't there's
not a mass surely for pubs on well
where's two things on that [ __ ] we don't
believe in anyway we are encouraging
people to drink far from it we are we've
got on here there's so we will believe
that the vast majority of the money we
make at this pub will come through food
soft drinks and and coffee we think
maybe soft drinks then we I really don't
understand you just open a cafe well
that's a fair point but this is the pump
company we run pubs and you absolutely
right if we were opening here and and
just serving hot drinks cold drinks no
alcohol and food who would be of no
interest to the press so we completely
understand that but we do run pubs we're
very transparent about it we've got the
necessary permissions we are a decent
company people now our pubs and I think
as an example if there's a coach party
passing by and there's 50 people in that
coach party and they want to come in
here and have same to eat and drink we
think that's a booed we think that's a
great thing for them to do you do a
photos I think I think a coach I think
the coach is more likely to be full of
football supporters and in a second
coach will arrive and it'd be rival
football supporters it'll be full of
people on their way to stag parties and
hand parties and it will be complete
nightmare you in fact are the devil
unless you're who are offering well
titian
to everybody you're offering a scenario
of Hell basically are you not well you
are you're assuming a lot and it's
obviously what you believe we don't
believe that is the case and we
generally don't and we
that when people come in here if example
you are a stag party and you come in and
you're gonna coach with others and you
have a couple of pints of beer what is
the problem you're not going to be honey
willing probably issue amazed that you
make what is a perfectly nice service
area and not very welcoming that's the
problem what actually actually if you
come in here as as other people already
have format for this morning you're fine
it's a wonderful looking pub and
actually sure it is I'm sure you just go
half a mile down the road why don't you
just get off the motorway you must admit
it's a really strange message and people
are questioning all the things we're not
allowed to do on the roads we're not
allowed use phones we're not allowed to
eat when we drive we're not allowed to
do is off of the wheel there's loads of
things we're not allowed to do but the
government deny saying yeah we're gonna
create a big pub what are you doing pubs
or you go and get coffee and pubs that's
what you do no you don't what again is
is it's not a big puppet and those might
be your personal views they might be the
views of a lot of people in England but
we actually think that a lot of people
will welcome this part but and we'd
rather take their views it may be the
view of a survey of a sales of people
from the RAC we completely understand
that if you open a pub or the motorway
Network we'd have to be naive to think
the broadcaster's wouldn't pick up the
fact that public motorway network
potential problem but we run our pubs
well and if someone actually wanted to
come from their home having drunk on to
motorway network they can if someone
actually wanted to go to the supermarket
50 metres over here buy alcohol they
could if someone wanted to come but they
don't that's the thing I don't really
there's a big difference between what
you do in private and what is personal
choice and what is in vailable to the
general public and what encourages the
general public and what tempts the
general public no I you know what you
know what we'll we'll see what the
general reaction is here the AAA the RAC
says there's no support for this at all
Charlotte what are you picking up here
this morning the feeling from people
today actually sandy says irresponsible
shameful just asking for trouble I pity
the people injured and dead in the
inevitable subsequent multiple pile-up
Frederic it's totally irresponsible
rates of drink driving will treble more
innocent people will be killed another
one here from Jim pubs on motorways
sanity no one drives up the motorway for
a drink then continues their journey too
easy okay Edward go should we only hope
we never have to do an interview with
you in the future and which there is a
pileup there is a fatality caused by
people drinking at a pub at a motorway
service station thank you for your time
thank you for arguing your cause